señor núñez bienvenido france24 los
mapuches dicen que desconoce por
completo el conflicto territorial con
ellos qué retos implica este conflicto
para el nuevo gobierno de chile y como
los está enfrentado
muchas gracias por la invitación implica
claramente un reto muy importante porque
este es el primer gobierno durante mucho
tiempo que cambia el tono dentro de la
el conflicto que existe entre el estado
de chile y el pueblo mapuche porque ha
propuesto el diálogo antes que el uso de
la fuerza y la conversación antes que el
empleo de alternativas que son más
drásticas como la declaración de estados
de emergencia o la declaración de la
utilización más bien de normativas
legales que son más drásticas de la
sanción de delitos que bajo otras
circunstancias podrían ser considerados
delitos comunes entonces el mismo
gobierno se ha puesto un techo o un piso
más bien dicho bien importante para
sortear este conflicto usted
precisamente menciona los estados de
emergencia y el gobierno anterior de
sebastián piñera decreto 1 en las
regiones mapuche y luego boris lo
levantó cuáles fueron las consecuencias
de las dos medidas
en un corto plazo es bien difícil de
evaluarlo certeramente pero pareciera
ser que hay dos visiones que se
confrontan bien técnicamente primero hay
algunos que piensan que la alternativa
es militarizar la zona y que eso crearía
una seguridad o generaría seguridad
dentro de la que se llama macro sola sur
y otros piensas que esto simplemente es
una especie de placebo que de alguna
forma da la sensación de seguridad o que
postergan los hechos de violencia que
naturalmente van a acontecer de todo un
conflicto para aquellos momentos o
intervalos en donde no están rigiendo
estos estados de excepción o estos
estados de emergencia y al parecer esta
acción armada de este grupo específico o
de sería justamente esta segunda lógica
aquí el placebo se levantó y el síntoma
reaparecer y muy brevemente cuáles son
los reclamos de los mapuches
los reclamos son básicamente primero un
reconocimiento a su pueblo segundo un
reconocimiento de sus tierras
ancestrales y tercero una cuestión que
quieren todas las naciones el respeto
básicamente y respeto porque el último
tiempo el gobierno que insisto ha tenido
un tono bastante dialogante que tiene de
reunión de emergencia sostuvo vamos a
dialogar pero sin presiones y el
gobierno también respeta sus costumbres
al momento de ingresar dentro de los
territorios porque se estaba comportando
entre el último tiempo como un gobierno
que irrumpe más que como un gobierno que
dialoga pero insisto el tono es bastante
adecuado para resolver este conflicto